A year ago, a core melt occurred in the Fukushima Daiichi Nuclear Power Station triggered by the earthquake and tsunami.
Even now, it is clear after the damage.
Convergence work is still ongoing.
Thousands of workers are involved in the removal of plays and the installation of fences The installation of the
Unit 1 building cover was completed in October, and the
face was installed to prevent the radioactive material from leaking into the Pacific Ocean.  The vinyl sheet hanging below the surface of the sea
is designed to catch the dragon species contaminated with radioactive substances. In
December, tepco announced that all three units had reached the cold shutdown.
It means that it finally shook to the floor,
but the nuclear problem has not been solved. The
reactor is yours. Cooling water is flowing out to the building and underground.
It
is necessary to return to the guidance,
and the site inside the reactor is still mysterious.
Workers can only enter before the war when the radioactivity level is too high and it becomes dangerous.
Taking a Chilean cedar breeze to monitor levels of radioactivity In
January I inserted a small camera into Unit 2 to a kindergarten but didn't see it very well
This colored Chile has deep sea radiation
The problem is not limited to the boundaries of the power plant. The
government announced that it will start a large-scale convergence work in April, but no one knows how to dispose of radioactively contaminated debris.
It does not have a radioactive waste storage area.
More than 100,000 Fukushima residents are still forced to live in evacuation due to the influence of the nuclear power plant.
Radioactivity is detected inside and outside the evacuation area.
So low levels of radioactivity and
good health Most of the evacuees who have no sleeves will probably be able to return home in the near future,
but it is unclear if there are people who will actually return home.
Keeping cool until the radioactive fuel collapses
The focus of work is on strengthening the fence of the power plant and fishing boats in preparation for future earthquakes.
It will take years before it can be confirmed, and
it will take more time to dismantle it.